はいというで公園でございますよねあの数が多すぎて寝ました
2日目ですそれで今日早速場面切り替えアイキャッチ見ていきましょう
4施設目前編でしていますのでぜひそちらをご覧下さいませ
まだまだたくさんありますので堅人は場面と場面が切り替わる一瞬のスキマ時間に何を
生み出すのかダーってこよ
[音楽]
05 e
塩レーダーすごい
[音楽]
わー
いいわーわーわー
p ん
[音楽]
前回のエンディングの王座で二迎合
を
すごい
柄パターン
アオヒトデ浅瀬がすごいて前回の王者ですよ
いやもう何かねぇ何だろう
政治なんだねなんかななんかすげー綺麗な感じがするんですよねエンディングの場面
きれいからこんな綺麗だったら俺のチャンネル
綺麗なチャンネルみたいに水はでしょ全然すばらしいです
英語
6なんか出てるけど
2エンディングのあのイラストとうまいことが増えてますね素晴らしいだぞ
動画を燃やし
あーおれがいれば損
[音楽]
すごいみんなねーなんか産後で出してくれますねー
ずう鯉参考を明白性はありがたいです
見てる方もねどういう感じで使うとかというのは混ざりやすい気がしますで go
を可愛らしいいいですねーねーがー
あースロットタイプねああーーあいきゃんぷるー
かーわーいー
めっちゃオシャレだったらいいと思います米軍
おおなるほど
何言ってるかわから何言ってるかわかんないけどビンディングの帯と合わせているこの
黄緑遠いところとても良いと思いますグッドですありがとうございますねーぞ
彼はよ
ずいぶん濁ってしますね素晴らしいですねカワイイですありがとうございます英語
バウンティーハンターパーン t 果たしてだけど今代行
おーかっこいい国家からの今度でてくるー
いいなぁいいですねおしゃれをされてが大
ああ
くっ
ハーフムーン
進めてみるっ
めっちゃ好きなんだけどもう前髪伸ばそう
朧になろうこれでチェックめっちゃ好きなんでここでもうクソめっちゃくちゃ迷うなぁ
鬼神伸ばしたくなっちゃうのみたらで行こう
かっこよなええっまってまっ
火病ありすげーいい感じだったろ
太鼓魚ちょっとポップですねやってめちゃくちゃいいと思いますし
ただ10日4やって書いたんですよ
第号
アナ可愛い素敵連リングダウンテールの多くていいですね
0号
ゴーヤ俺の声を国会つまで作ってくれてまさにありがとうございますからもうもやしで
はありませんペコ
うわぁめっちゃくちゃカラフルほどただもう一つだけありますで go
ますね
誰誰誰だって持ってきたし俺だったあ
戻ってきて a まだあひらがなバージョンね凄い絵面は2割と好きですよ
ただ
戦国時代で go
あで来校ミッキーにというあの可愛いけどところさあ
ただ英語
大瀬木スティポップでいいですねで go
お前めっちゃホットりゃーもうオレンジの後ろのここを完璧に再現して分
すごいな4組でなパンダどこまでありがとうございます黒亭まで一緒だしない子
ああーっぽいぽいぽいぽいぞなんか見たことあるかを使いやすそうな患者攻めしますよ
英語
[音楽]
格好やメッツに描画するんですけど
5位何ネオン
パンマンえっぽいめっちゃスキー
[音楽]
僕なんか充実めちゃくちゃさを経営する憧れてる人がいるスーパー賛成なんですよね
すごいな a go
セブ周りを英語
terf
英語
可愛いかわいいニャー待ってちょっとこれはいいなぁ
めっちゃキュートやん
その3パターンあるよね廃絶来ない
エマ良い結構で刺さったの俺ね今回変更刺さってるのが多いんですよね書いてる2スト
だけど結構ありまして取れも捨てがたいなこれ一個だけ三よってかもせなくなっ
分かりません最後までわかりませもうちょっとあるんですけども
ひょっとしたら今中で砕氷に特番が生まれるかもしれません姉御
っぽそうし一方英語
ああああああ
といっしょ名がっ
ああこういうなんで go
1なんかめっちゃ凝ってる感じがすごいめい子
つい撮ったなぁ可愛かったなあと思ういいへ go
あー落ちちゃったはいというわけで発表を変え終了でございますってくださった皆様
本当にありがとうございましたらノミネートされなかった中でもいいのが酢酸とか本当
に良かったです
ございますそういうわけで
[音楽]
ブーバーしますパターレッスン
はいというわけで頭の今
ましたどうぞ一個だけが採用されますよ初だったんですけどもエンディングと違って
ですね見てれって何種類かあってもいいかっていうのは気がしました疎通のホラー
みたいかた負けないして俺も飽きない気がしててちょっと現世に減衰を繰り返しで
どうぞも見直してこんなんでいろいろ考えた結果採用された先んん
[音楽]
呉三桂皆さん
いや後コバエはいいかなと思うその場に応じて場面切り替えで5種類
嬉しいアワードがすごいなんか素敵な感じない気がしてきました
というわけで私はの一つ長いなんだ前編にまでます事項便後編ちゃ
扁平に割れまして後編にも選ばれる奴がありますので早速優勝された後殺菌いていき
ましょう
一作品名
島の子 house さんの作品ですこちらです8号
こちらです
左右自由としましては意味が分からなすぎますあのこれすごい大事な要素も気がして
ましてわかるどうかになっていないんですよ
僕はですけど既存にとらわれというような場面9回あいきゃって超なものを使って言っ
ては次の事件のクリエイティビティにはたどり着けないと思ってるねそれをご覧
ください真ん中は間違いなく僕だとして右の黄色い一を目指す銀色1左のピンク色や形
が待っていると左のちょっと高めの位置にいる緑で分何を表しているのか全く分から
ないんですよ
だがそこがいい何か分からない
中によって見てる人がちょっと頭がバグっちゃってついて日に腐るそういうきっかけに
なるかもしれません素晴らしい作品ですおめでとうございます作用ございます
ついでに作品目朝日が対応さの責任ですぜひ高
はいこちらですよめでとうございますこれはもうね純正に何か疾走感が良かったです
ずん子に一目惚れいたしました
素敵な下げんでしたありがとうございます水で3作品名をすけさんの作品です
8号
こちらですすばらせてあの採用理由といたしましてはロケットに乗っているのがとても
彼は後何でしょうやっぱこのゲーム的な感じがすごく好きなんですけどもたくさんそう
いうゲーム系のば引きで彦作っていただいたんですけども一番シンプルで見やすいし音
がそんな波がないと言いますかどんな場面でも使いやすいような一定のテンションを
貼る切ると感情を感じられませんでしただそれがいいです場面切り替えにおいでー無機
質なものとても使いやすいですありがとうございます
めっちゃ
何喋ってるアドにさっきありますからね次の作品は落書きパンツさんが作品です
英語
おおめでとうございます
これですね
まあ前髪と動かないものなんですよ8日ないものを動かしている
これクリアへ行ってみて何です
場所るっていうか音になるんじゃないと言いますかチェックたくチェックて狂ってる
だけすごい使いやすいんですよねもう県気に入っ
雑感開くになるような顔にも感じられますが素晴らしい言えてありがとうございます
それでは最後の砂金で最後に選ばれましたのは
[音楽]
エントリーナンバー単弁60 the ヴァン迷彩ハンターそゲットさんの作品です
代行
大こちらですありがとうございますもうね見てもらったらわかるかもですけどかわいい
のところいっしょなんにすぐカラフルなんですけど
さらに3パターン準備して僕受かってて巨大なクマの色の組み合わせで作られていて
すごいかわいいですねこれはもうね女性視聴者が集まりますありがとうございます
っていう感情5つの場面切り替えにさせていただきましたちょっと改めて見てみ
ましょうこんな感じです
ああああああ
[音楽]
はいというわけですねこれはで思いつつれなんですね回だったかなと思いますねジスと
全部本当に採用する理由がしっかりあって僕もすごい気に入ってますし他にはめちゃ
いい作品があったんですけども僕のチャンネルはそんななんかかわいい結局チャンネル
でしたわけでもないしでめちゃくちゃテーション高い元気なチャンネルでしたいいわけ
でもないなんかそのはじめ処女っていうよくわかんない空気感じっす
メイクチャンネルにしたいなと思ってるんでその期間にあった把握もなく低くもないぜ
必要な空気感の場面切り替え合わせていただきました本当にありがとうございます
いうわけでチャンネルの動画の変化結構ガラッと変わると思うので今後もそれとも注目
しながらぜひ見てって下さい最近なんか調べたんですけども意外とチャンネル登録して
ない人が結構動画見ていくだ
立ってるみたいなのでよかったらチャンネル登録してくださいよろしくお願いしますね
また次回の動画でお会いしましょう see you ですいい
あっは
[音楽]
blr